la parole est à monsieur didier mandelli
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
du numérique
monsieur le ministre hier c'était la
journée de la justice morte en france
une grande première
tous les membres et collaborateurs des
six organisations professionnelles du
droit conseil national des barreaux pour
les avocats conseil supérieur du
notariat conseil national des greffiers
des tribunaux de commerce le conseil
national des administrateurs judiciaires
et de mandataires judiciaires
le conseil national des commissaires
priseurs judiciaires et la chambre
nationale des huissiers de justice
étaient en grève pour manifester contre
votre projet de loi pour la croissance
et l'activité
les études des cabinets étaient fermés
cette mobilisation sans précédent
symbolisera colère froide qui se
généralise dans notre pays
la tension monte chaque jour un peu plus
monsieur le ministre dans votre projet
de loi fourre-tout je reprends
l'expression du premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste jean christophe
cambadélis
vous avez l'ambition de redresser
l'économie française je partage cet
objectif et je l'encouragé même selon
vous l'un des moyens pour y parvenir est
de réformer les professions réglementées
notamment les professions juridiques
ces dernières sont les garants de la
sécurité juridique des français la plus
grande vigilance s'impose donc ce que
l'on vous reproche monsieur le ministre
c'est votre précipitation et une
concertation a minima des organisations
professionnelles concernées
l'étude d'impact de l'avant projet de la
loi pour les professions juridiques est
une suite d'approximations et
d'interprétation de chiffres et de fait
le conseil d'état a émis le 8 décembre
dernier des réserves sur une mesure
phare de votre projet de loi la liberté
d'installation des notaires des
huissiers de justice et des commissaires
priseurs
il estime qu'il a une rupture
caractérisée de l'égalité devant les
charges publiques
d'autre part les professionnels s'étonne
à juste titre que le premier ministre
est confiée au ministère de l'économie
de l'industrie du numérique la tâche de
réformer les professions juridiques
réglementées et non au ministère de la
justice
je vous demande donc aujourd'hui
d'écouter les professionnels du droit en
france pour cela monsieur le ministre
donnez vous du temps pour un dialogue
constructif c'est la seule méthode qui
permettra d'engager une modernisation
attendu de l'exercice de ces professions
réglementées
pourquoi monsieur le ministre ne pas
retirer votre projet de loi tous les
articles concernant les professions
juridiques les intégrer modifiée dans le
projet de loi relatif à la justice du
21ème siècle qui sera présentée au
printemps 2015 par la chancellerie ne
pensez vous pas que ce temps nécessaire
au dialogue et la concertation tant
demandée par ces professions évitera
ainsi de cristalliser les oppositions et
de renforcer les blocages prendre la
parole et à monsieur emmanuel macron me
disent que l'économie de l'industrie et
du numérique il avait la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'abord je respecte
et j'entends ces professionnels du droit
qui ont manifesté hier
je les ai vus reçu je les ai vus avec la
garde des sceaux et j'étais ir soir avec
certains d'entre vous dans un débat avec
les huissiers donc quand on débat et
qu'on veut échanger sur des idées je
suis toujours preneur est à disposition
et je m'étonne
au demeurant qu on puisse manifester
contre un projet de voie le jour où il
est déposé là aussi vraisemblablement
109 sans avoir véritablement pris
connaissance mais qu'importe
qu'importe c'est la vie politique dans
laquelle nous vivons au final alors
monsieur le sénateur moi je voulais vous
poser une question en est il des
réformes comme des économies c'est à
dire que vous en voulez toujours
davantage
mais vous êtes toujours contre celle
qu'on fait et donc ils en seraient ils
en seraient des réformes mais les bonnes
sont sans doute celles que vous n'avez
pas fait pendant dix ans monsieur le
sénateur mais les réformes c'est
toujours la même chose
c'est à dire c'est fait les réformes
ailleurs mais pas chez moi et c'est la
spécialité
mais s'il faudrait pas les faire et donc
les réformes ça ne serait pas chez les
professions réglementées ça devrait être
chez les salariés ça ne devrait pas être
ici ça devrait être chez les autres ça
n'a pas de sens et donc l'esprit
l'esprit de ce projet de loi c'est quoi
ces de débloquer la société française
partout où elle peut l'être c'est de
moderniser les conditions notre
fonctionnement partout où ils peuvent
l'être
et en l'espèce je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire que c'est un projet qui est
uniquement porté par bercy en aucun cas
le premier ministre a redit ici il l'a
dit hier
ce projet est porté également par la
garde des sceaux défendu par la garde
des sceaux est préparé avec elle est
préparée avec elle et si vous regardez
le texte qui a été déposée hier elle est
le garant de ce dispositif
alors maintenant revenons précisément
sur ce dont il s'agit parce que
finalement ce dos ce que vous défendez
in concreto c'est l'existence intangible
d'intérêt à qui eh bien on je vais vous
dire parlons concrètement sur l'emploi
la liberté d'installation que nous
proposons régulé qui nous déstabilise ni
les territoires ni les professionnels en
place elle permettra de créer plus elle
permettra de créer ces garanties dans le
texte
plusieurs offices notariaux elle créera
de créer elle permettra de créer de
l'activité de l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi
aujourd'hui il y a rien qui justifie
monsieur le sénateur dans le système où
nous vivons il n'y a rien qui justifie
enfin conclure monsieur l'union
république l'emploi et entrepreneuriat
nous soit réservé à quelques-uns donc
oui j'y crois je crois que l'on peut
préserver l'égalité la sécurité
juridique parce qu'elle est préservée
par ce texte de loi
je crois qu'on peut préserver
véritablement les fondements de notre
république qui est préservée dans ce
texte de loi et en même temps créer de
l'activité réformer parce que la réforme
elle doit être partagé par tous parce
que l'effort ne vaut que s'il est
partagé par tous c'est comme ça que ce
sera efficace